the Earth's climate is changing and each
one of us plays a role in the products
we buy in the electricity we use and in
the energy that powers our businesses
manufacturing agriculture transport
waste power generation and other sectors
release carbon dioxide and other gases
into the atmosphere where they trap heat
from the Sun but more carbon dioxide
traps more of the heat leading to global
warming the result changes in our
climate with ripple effects on weather
food production water supplies human
health and more but there are smart ways
forward these include emissions trading
which is the cornerstone of the European
Union's strategy to tackle climate
change head-on for more than a decade
the EU has worked to cut its greenhouse
gas emissions with the help of the
world's first largest and
longest-running international system for
trading emissions allowances and the
system keeps growing stronger in a
nutshell the EU emissions trading system
or ETS creates a financial incentive for
the biggest emitters to cutback how well
since 2005 the ETS has set a cap on the
total amount of greenhouse gases
companies can emit each year and
requires monitoring of these emissions a
fixed number of allowances which are the
currency of the carbon market are issued
and each year companies hold enough
allowances to cover their emissions or
face significant fines don't have enough
cut your emissions or buy extra
allowances from another emitter have
extra allowances keep them for next year
or sell them this flexibility ensures
that emissions are cut where it costs
the least to do so over time the cap is
reduced fewer allowances are issued
techniques to cut emissions or develop
and total emissions drop companies have
a financial incentive to cut their
emissions or pay others to do so today
this cap-and-trade system covers around
half the --use emissions and more than
three-quarters of the International
carbon market interest is growing among
business and government leaders around
the world the e u--'s ets proves that
putting a price on carbon is possible
and makes economic sense this flexible
cost-effective and business friendly
approach is helping the EU move faster
toward a low-carbon greener future visit
our website to find out more about how
emissions trading works to secure our
future
[Music]